and ready to block here on this third
down play he's traveled a good pocket
and he throws it over the middle and
it's caught and there's space to run and
there's space to run to the end zone for
Marvin Harrison Jr it's a touchdown for
Ohio States
first try by the way after a great punt
that was a 96-yard drive the last 42
covered by Marvin Harrison Jr to put the
Buckeyes on the board who's coaching
Ohio state that in big games there's
always a player that's going to rise up
to the occasion it was abuka and in this
particular case the big player rising to
the occasion is Marvin Harrison Jr he
already has a long touchdown catch
safety over toward Marvin Harrison Jr
because he's able to get behind this
coverage again a phenomenal athlete but
his ability to track the football not
going to the ground
pass to ibuka for eight another throw by
Stroud looking for a lot more than eight
he's got he's got it more than eight
touchdown Marvin Harrison Jr number two
on the day
[Applause]
Ohio State Joshua you see the backfield
action you just got hit with the big run
take the top off the defense take a shot
down the field CJ Stroud back to throw
for the Buckeyes and down the middle a
Mecca abuka and he is gone
foreign
go through progression step up in the
pocket nice touch pass hit your wide
open receiver it's great football right
there since they've settled on playing
him at receiver on a touchdown last week
got a couple of passes early in the game
today Stroud throwing this time is for
Marvin Harrison Jr and it's a trifecta
of touchdowns for Harrison as he secures
it with four seconds left in the third
quarter it's a contested catch this is a
tough throw into a small closing window
they're able to come up with it that's
phenomenal guys you're gonna have to
accept that and the Buckeye players do
play fake
[Music]
[Applause]
Stover first and goal pick on him a
little bit and they're going to try to
work on him 48-yard pickup and a first
down
this is an important play early if
they're gonna hit a field in this
momentum buckeyes need four
Stroud Zips in wide open a total bust
and ibuca is running free oh the way
from Ohio State touchdown
[Applause]
miscommunication that time was by the
defense 69-yard strike
so many people up they're showing
man-to-man on the outside right well
watch at the snap of the ball they drop
out Rush three and drop eight plays Zone
the problem is they bust his own nobody
gets into that back third to take away
the threat of a downfield throw we
talked about some of the use that they
have on the back end and it's one thing
to be able to that's why he's in there
to move people out of the way
he's got Fleming running free and Julian
Fleming battles to the end zone
touchdown Ohio State the third long
downfield strike for Stroud 51 yards to
the back end Justin white right there
he's just you see the safety he needs to
be helping out the defensive back
Brantley so you can look at with zero
and say what the heck was he thinking
but white it was a corner trying to play
safety needed to come over to help him
out got his eyes in the backfield
see the progressive pylon cam looks like
he breaks the plan goes into the end
zone
[Applause]
CJ Stroud
once again frighteningly efficient
against the Spartans I thought Ohio
state would play better today but
they're certainly playing better here in
the second half this trial delivers deep
down the field
and he'll walk in touchdown Buckeyes 79
yards
of 30 yards or more and this one comes
from Julian Fleming it's a really
straight post route and he's going to be
working against Cooper de Jean who gives
him too much space great throw great
throw in stride Fleming is able to just
catch that one and head to the End Zone
Third and ten to the 25.
Stroud out of the shotgun trips to the
top of your screen here's CJ Stroud
winds up delivers down the field cut and
a first down Marvin Harrison Jr on
Caitlyn King does such a good job at the
line of scrimmage of getting space and
look there early in the round a bit was
shove off and then he's able to create
this space and it's a beautiful throw
from CJ Stroud one of the things that
the Ohio State receivers talked about
all week now has got to commit those
resources and they snap it quick again
second and seven Stroud delivers down
the field
up inside the five
and a hookah finally thus we've seen all
day they've held abuka in check and
that's the best Catch of the Day for
number two
[Applause]
second and nine CJ Stroud keeps again CJ
strong down the sideline
and out of bounds
running has been the producer of a
couple the big plays today this one for
44. yeah all by Design got a great block
by Marvin Harrison Jr and the tight end
Kate Stover
caught northwestern's defense napping a
little bit
step out no he stayed in
all the way down inside the fight
first down and ten at the 42 Stroud
winds up goes deep has a man caught
Marvin Harrison Jr touchdown
marvelous Mar 58 yards
best of the country folks
[Applause]
so what does the safety have to do he's
got to get involved in the Run game they
go that run fake and then boom Harrison
is by him because they have to commit
the resources to stopping Byron Williams
that's why he's out of gas I would not
be looking in his direction if I'm CJ
Stroud
third and ten
right into the hands
first down Buckeyes
just a look he just runs them right here
on a little short route they run this
the Deep ball here so you're saving your
receiver who's gassed on the left
instead you're trying to attack
territory straw winds up throws the Deep
ball side
Marvin Harrison Jr marvelous
42 yards
crowd makes him pay watch as Michigan's
going to try to Blitz but they do it
from the safety position way deep Gus
that's called from depth you're never
going to get all the way to the
quarterback and Stroud knows as soon as
that safety blitzes he's got one-on-one
coverage on the outside and delivers an
absolute dime to Marvin Harrison watch
at the top of the route A little nudge
to create separation there it was on
Jamal Green and he's able to create that
separation and then the beautiful throw
from CJ Stroud right in the perfect spot
and Harrison extends into the end zone
last four possessions for these two
teams touchdown field goal touchdown
touchdown I bet you this is for now
territory for Ohio State is Stroud
underneath
it down at the Michigan 15. while the
safety split way wide and what does that
leave it leaves the seam route wide open
ibuka is able to get over the top of the
second level Defender and it's a
completion